for millions of workers around the world
the first of May is their day in the
late 19th century American labor unions
were fed up fed up with being overworked
in dangerous conditions and with little
pay
so in 1884 the federation of organized
trades and labor unions met in Chicago
and had one major demand an eight-hour
workday and on May 1st 1886 over 300,000
American workers went on strike three
days later thousands of strikers met in
Haymarket Square where a riot broke out
between cops and workers a bomb was
thrown into the crowd killing several
people it was called the Haymarket
massacre and today May 1st is known as
International Workers day while every
country's workers have a different
history behind May Day they all
commemorate those who have and continue
to give their lives for workers justice
you